CARRIE ROWE: Yeah, but I
think they won't cut
to me until my app.
ALI ASHFAR: So not even
when I introduce you?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
We have the single of her right
now, so if you introduce
her we can cut to that.
ALI ASHFAR: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's see.
MALE SPEAKER: Cut this?
STEVE BAZYL: And feel free
if I'm going to add
color or ask questions.
ALI ASHFAR: Stupidest goddamn
Hangout I've ever seen.
[LAUGHTER]
ALI ASHFAR: Are we ready
for some football?
Goddamn, that's dumb.
STEVE BAZYL: That'd be great.
Just like, hey, we've got
a mouthful of chew.
Wearing our white gaiters.
CARRIE ROWE: How much free
storage do users get on Drive?
ALI ASHFAR: Internet.
STEVE BAZYL: 15.
ALI ASHFAR: Yeah, 15.
STEVE BAZYL: 15 now.
CARRIE ROWE: 15 gigabytes?
STEVE BAZYL: Well, it's 15
shared amongst Gmail and.
ALI ASHFAR: Plus photos?
STEVE BAZYL: Yes.
ALI ASHFAR: I always forget
the other one.
CARRIE ROWE: That's
something that we
announced last week, right?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So this was the outro,
I believe.
And when I hit it,
I got a shot of
Carrie for some reason.
And then it went green.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
STEVE BAZYL: [INAUDIBLE]
underneath.
ALI ASHFAR: It's really useful
for like 95% of cases, and
then every now and then you need
to do something, and then
it's like what.
CARRIE ROWE: App of the week.
You know what would make
the GDL more fun?
Having a dog.
In the GDL.
STEVE BAZYL: Go bring
him down.
CARRIE ROWE: We could just like
put him on the table.
Cooper, sit.
STEVE BAZYL: I'll
bring my cat.
ALI ASHFAR: You would have to
deal with me like sneezing
constantly during the--
CARRIE ROWE: That's right.
Because of your allergy.
ALI ASHFAR: Exactly.
CARRIE ROWE: Sorry we
could [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE BAZYL: I'll start bringing
my cats to work.
ALI ASHFAR: No.
CARRIE ROWE: I would like
that, actually.
I like cats.
ALI ASHFAR: Don't do that.
See, cats are the only thing
I like less than dogs.
Goldfish, that's a pet.
CARRIE ROWE: How do
you feel about
animals, pets in general?
ALI ASHFAR: So my favorite pet,
the one I had the closest
relationship to, was
a guinea pig.
CARRIE ROWE: Oh yeah.
ALI ASHFAR: Have you ever
had guinea pigs?
I've had guinea pigs since--
CARRIE ROWE: My sisters
both had guinea pigs.
ALI ASHFAR: I had like loads.
And they were like really
intelligent animals.
CARRIE ROWE: Yeah, they're
really smart.
ALI ASHFAR: Really smart.
Really sociable.
Really cool.
CARRIE ROWE: So your patronus
would be a guinea pig?
ALI ASHFAR: My patronus
would be--
STEVE BAZYL: At I/O, where we
talked about how to get your
app noticed in Drive.
And during that talk, we
went over a few things.
A lot of this talking about the
opportunity behind Drive.
As well as a few tips for how
your app can stand out among
all the apps that
are integrated.
I don't want to repeat
too much of that.
I want to go into a few things
in a little bit more detail
that we didn't have time to
go to during that talk.
But for those who haven't yet
seen it, I would suggest later
on go and try to watch
that session online.
You can find it on YouTube
or linked to off
developers.google.com.
So there are a few things that
I focused on during the talk
on how to get your app
noticed that I
want to show in practice.
How this actually affects how
an app appears to a user.
And to do that, I'm going to
take a look at one of our
sample apps.
This is the Realtime Cube.
It's a demo app that we
used when we launched
the Realtime API.
And it's a simple 3D cube puzzle
game that you can play
with your friends.
So I want to show just a
screenshot here of what the
application looks
like when it's
presented to users in Drive.
And you can see here, it's
a little bit hard to see.
And this really speaks to the
first problem that this app
has, which is, as a user, if I
see that I'm not really going
to be enticed by that.
It's a screenshot of the
application, which, by itself,
isn't very interesting.
And it's really hard to make
out what the app is doing
other than the cube.
It's the only thing
that's really
prominent in that image.
But the text is far, far, far
too small to really read
anything about.
And likewise, if we were to
actually take a look at this
for real, let's take a look
at the set of apps.
And you can see here, all the
different apps here have
fairly bright, fairly
large fonts.
Colorful, very enticing
images that really
capture people's attention.
So actually, I want
to go back here.
And here's the app.
And actually, that's the only
thing that this app shows us
is just the screenshot.
So not a great sales job at
really enticing us to use the
application.
And, of course, there's the text
of this and everything.
Which, in this particular
case, isn't that bad.
So I'm not going to spend a lot
of time looking at that.
But do realize that this stuff
is very important.
And as a user, there's really
no reason why I would ever
want to install this application
just based off
that screenshot.
I really want something
more from that.
Kind of even a little bit more
surprising, is that screenshot
probably shouldn't have
ever been approved
in the first place.
This really violates just about
every guideline that we
have for what these tiles
are supposed to be.
And you can see these in
the Chrome Web Store
Documentation.
But the text is unreadable.
There's far too much
white space.
Just everything about it just
fails on the criteria.
And this is--
not to fault the person
who did this.
It is just a demo app.
But it's a good teaching
lesson as well.
ALI ASHFAR: Was it you?
STEVE BAZYL: No,
it was not me.
I'm not going to name
names, but--
ALI ASHFAR: I think
it was you.
STEVE BAZYL: No.
[LAUGHS]
So I took a stab at kind
of redesigning this.
Fair warning, I am not
a UI designer.
But I do have reasonable
skill with Photoshop.
Good enough to take a stock
photo or stock image and throw
on some text.
And came up with something
like this.
So we have something where the
text is much more prominent.
There's not a lot of it.
Just the app name.
Very, very short description
of what this does.
We're playing.
We're playing with people.
It's collaborative.
And some bright, colorful cubes
that catch your attention.
Of course, if this were a real
app, I would want to hire an
actual graphics designer to
do this and not just whip
together something in five
minutes with a Google search.
But it's a step up.
And it gives you kind of an
idea, not a huge time
investment can actually make
a big difference in
how that app appears.
And now when I'm looking at
this, it's actually something
that stands out.
It's bright.
Catches my attention.
And then I'm more inclined
to go in and check out
what that app does.
So one of the other things that
we talked about at the
I/O talk was how the data that
the app creates in Drive
appears to users.
And one of the things that,
for this application in
particular, because it's a
very visual application.
Actually, let's just go
over and just show you
what the app does.
For those who haven't played
with it, just we can go here
and rotate cubes around.
And of course, if we had
multiple people in we'd see
our collaborators up
in the corner.
We would see their moves
if they were
rotating the cube as well.
It's pretty fun stuff if you
like solving puzzles.
And you can sit there and
torture your friends or just
screw with each other by
undoing their moves.
You can have a lot
of fun with it.
But anyways, so that's it.
So as you can see, there's
not a lot of text.
There's really not much
I can search on.
It's purely visual.
And when we look at how this app
appears, ignoring this one
up in the top left, but all we
see when we're looking at the
grid view for our Drive is just
the icon for the app.
And it doesn't really
tell me much about
that particular game.
Even if I go and click in here
in the light box where I get
all these really nice
previews, here
I just get no preview.
So not really useful.
If I have five or six puzzles
that I happen to be working
on, and I want to go and find
that particular one that I
just, oh, you know what?
I think I figured out
what the moves are.
I'm going have to go and click
through each one in
order to find it.
So one of the things you can do
to make this a lot easier
for users is provide a rendering
of that content.
So I actually kind of mocked
it up a little bit earlier.
But in this case,
using the API.
Just uploading a screenshot
of the API.
Now we can actually see the
state of that cube where we
last left it off.
And also in here you can see, in
our thumbnail view, we can
actually see that same
image here as well.
So again, if we have five or
six games, I could actually
quickly recognize what that
particular game is just by
glancing at the screen here.
To do that it's really easy.
ALI ASHFAR: So we have
thumbnails there.
But as you showed us, the
thumbnail also appears in the
preview for the--
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
In fact, I would actually
probably rename what that
thumbnail is.
Because the rules for how you
can create thumbnails are
actually pretty generous
in terms of size.
You can go up to 2 megabytes of
standard image formats, PNG
is preferred.
And you can actually do a fairly
high resolution image
in just that 2 megabytes.
It's pretty easy to do.
The only thing you have to
do is just Base64 encode
it and update it.
So I actually have here in the
API's console, this is how I
was able to do it for that
particular image or that
particular file.
Just use the API's console
to inject it.
Really all we had to do
was set thumbnail.
You can actually zoom in
a little bit here.
Set the MIME type and
provide the image.
You're only seeing this cut
off a little bit here.
But you can see there
are requests.
We have a really, really,
really long Base64.
Hey, I just lost my
[INAUDIBLE] here.
Let's go back.
Oh well, I just lost it.
But basically it's a
Base64-encoded image.
It does need to be
web safe Base64,
which is the only catch.
So you do have a choice.
The only difference is just how
some of the symbols are
encoded like pluses and slashes
and equal signs.
But it's pretty easy to go.
If you don't have a web safe
Base64 encoder, you can just
do a quick regex and fix that.
But pretty easy to inject
that image.
Once you do that, you get
all the cool stuff.
You get the grid view.
You get the preview
images as well.
You can do the same thing
for indexable text too.
If this app had text, maybe we
would even want to do some
synthetic text in terms of
maybe the game state.
Is the puzzle solved
or is not solved?
We could even index the move
list, all the rotations.
Something that would
be interesting.
So pretty easy to do.
And I want to take a little
side track because
I had to fake this.
And I planned on actually having
this be a live demo.
And it turns out there's some
interesting issues with
capturing images of CSS 3D
transforms that make it
impossible.
So things like PhantomJS, which
a lot of people use for
screenshots, don't actually
support those transforms.
So I had to fake it here.
But there's a couple issues
with this that I think are
worth talking about with
relation to certain apps.
So the Realtime API.
When you have an app that uses
it, you don't have an explicit
save point.
So it's not always clear what
you should actually be
snapshotting in terms
of the image.
In this case, I did
this manually.
I said, this is the point
that I want to save it.
But if I have a user who's
making a serious move and
they're playing for 5 or 10
minutes, do you wait for them
to close their browser?
What happens if you have
multiple people in there if
one person closes and the
other person continues?
So the idea is you don't want
to necessarily update the
image too often.
Basically you're just burning
through a quota.
It's wasteful.
And given that these are really
just snapshots at a
point in time to help users
recognize it, you don't
necessarily need to be super
accurate in terms of making
sure that that preview is a
perfect representation of what
the content of the file is
at any point in time.
So you can do things a
little bit lazily.
Defer things.
And for something like the
Realtime API, a simple trick
you can do, assuming that we
had a way to render this on
the server, would be any time
that the file is changed,
queue up some sort of event.
Send this in the server,
send a time stamp.
And then after some period of
time, 5, 10, 15 minutes later,
then you can just snapshot
that file.
And then if more collaborators
come along, you may want to
coalesce all those different
modifications into one event.
That way you're not burning
through your quota too quickly
in order to keep this
stuff up to date.
Really it's important, but you
don't want to necessarily kill
yourself or burn through quota
too quickly in order to keep
this information up to date.
Same thing for indexable text.
You can do the same thing
where you don't want to
reindex on every word that
somebody's typing.
Just do it at some reasonable
interval after there's a
little bit of idleness.
You know, because honestly,
people aren't going to go back
and look for that file
immediately as soon as they're
done editing.
They're probably going to come
back the next day, the next
week, or so on.
So just put in a little delay
and you really should be fine.
But anyway, I had planned on
making this all really nice
and interactive until I ran into
issues with capturing the
actual image.
But for most other applications,
if you're using
Canvas or something like that,
it's really not that
difficult to do.
So those were just
the two tricks.
There are some things this app
does right, that I want to
point out as well.
One of the things I mentioned
in the I/O talk was the
importance of the
OAuth screen.
The importance of choosing
the right scopes.
This app is written to use the
fewest amount of permissions
that it needs in
order to work.
One of that things that was a
follow-up question during that
talk was, if you had any stats
about what the impact of
choosing the right or
wrong scope is.
And I actually did a little
bit of research into that.
And it turns out that the
approval rates for apps that
use a very restrictive scope,
like drive.file, is about 10%
better, actually a little over
10% better than apps that
request access to the
user's entire drive.
And so users actually do pay
attention to this stuff.
And it's important that when
you're building your app that
you don't necessarily choose the
scope that's easiest, but
you choose the one that's right
and reflective of what
your app actually needs to do.
So that's just some examples
of how those tips from the
talk come into practice
and how they affect
how your app appears.
We weren't able to show a lot
of this in the talk, but
hopefully this gives you a
little bit more context for
how these changes can impact
how your app appears.
And if you haven't seen the
talk, go ahead and watch it.
And of course, check back on
the community and we'll
happily have discussions about
any other follow-up questions
that you might have.
So that's it.
I'm going to turn
it back to Ali.
ALI ASHFAR: OK, thanks, Steve.
That's really interesting.
So remember that and make your
apps appear useful and
welcoming to users.
Give them the right images.
Give them the right indexable
text, give them the right
thumbnails, and people will
use your application.
That make sense, I think.
And this is how to do it.
So thanks very much, Steve.
And now we'll be going to our
regular weekly installment of
Carrie's App of the Week.
CARRIE ROWE: Thanks, Ali.
So today I wanted to talk
about a photo app
called Loupe Collage.
And photos are really prominent
in the Drive ecosystem.
I think we announced last week
across Drive and some of our
other platforms users get 15
gigabytes of shared storage.
So photos are a great way for
users to take advantage of all
this storage.
So let's take a look
at Loupe Collage.
So I've already installed
the app.
And you can see right here in
the Create interface that
we've given a lot of good
real estate to apps.
So right here let's select
Loupe Collage.
And once this loads, you'll see
that in the next step I
can easily add photos.
And Loupe has done a great job
of integrating with lots of
different photo platforms,
including Google Drive.
So when I go to Google Drive,
all of my photos are ready for
me to select to add
to this collage.
And let's select a few.
I'm a huge fan of animals,
as you can tell.
So we'll add the photos.
And there's a lot of really
fun, creative art projects
that you can do with
these photos.
So let's select a coffee mug.
And I can, once it's created,
I can have fun watching all
the animation.
So once it's created,
I can save this.
Let's call it coffee mug.
And then once it's saved, I can
really easily save it back
to my Drive folder.
And then when I go to Drive, I
will be able to see this right
here in my Drive.
And so I can open it
up and here it is.
And so this is a really great
integration with Drive.
Now, Steve just talked about
how important it is to get
your app noticed inside
of Drive.
And I wanted to just mention
one other thing that Loupe
could have done to have
even more visibility.
So a lot of users will view
their photos in this nice
shadow box right here.
They can swipe through them.
One other access point
is right here
in this Open button.
So when I have my photo loaded,
I can choose to open
it with certain apps.
And so right here if I click
Open, I can see all the
connected apps I have.
So this is a really easy
integration for Loupe.
They can add it right here.
So any photos that I have when
I'm viewing them, I can access
them directly from the Loupe
application by clicking here.
So this is a really great
integration of a photo app
with Google Drive.
We love to see developers
creating apps for photos.
And we look forward to seeing
what else you guys can create.
Back to you guys.
ALI ASHFAR: Thanks, Carrie.
So yeah, I absolutely
love that app.
Have you used that one?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, actually I
worked with them when they
were first doing it.
It's a really fun app
to play with.
I have created my fair share
of collages with it.
ALI ASHFAR: And of course, once
your photos are in Drive
you can share them.
You can comment on them.
You can do all the cool things
that Drive offers.
I keep beating the drum, but
this is the place where the
files should be.
This is where you should
put them, in Drive.
So thanks very much
for that, Carrie.
And hopefully we can get
in touch with Loupe
and ask them to--
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
That's something that should
be a pretty easy
fix for them to do.
And especially for things like
opening multiple files and
everything.
That support is there
in the API.
Which may not have been there
when they first did the
integration, but it's about time
to go back and revisit.
ALI ASHFAR: OK.
So thanks, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
Join us again, and over
the next few weeks
we're pretty excited.
We're launching some stuff
we've been working on for
quite a long time.
So please stay tuned to find
out what that all is.
And hopefully we'll
see you next time.
From Steve and from Carrie
and myself, goodbye.
CARRIE ROWE: Bye.